- On this episode I talk
about turning points,
content, real estate, and chugging.
(upbeat music)
You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and welcome to Episode 36
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Fun fact about the number 36:
it's the last time I'm doing
a fun fact about a number.
- [Voiceover] Barry asks:
"Gary, love to hear your opinion
on whether a PR company
or a person should be
overseeing social media for a business."
- Barry, great question,
and before I even answer it,
I just want to thank you
for being a long time
interactor friend with me.
I don't like using the word fan,
but I say it sometimes, it just slips.
Barry, I've always
enjoyed our conversations
on Twitter over the last four years,
so thrilled to have you on the show.
I think I know where you're
going with this question,
which is the notion of,
VaynerMedia was built
on coming into companies and taking the
social media away from PR companies.
Some of the bigger PR companies
in the world right now
have built out social media departments
and they've done a nice
job, to varying degrees.
I wanted to answer this question because
I want to get people around the psychology
of the difference between PR and social,
and why I do think that,
of course there's people,
hundreds of people in
this company have worked
in PR before, so there's
some great things about PR.
Being able to handle
pressure, the speed of it.
The difference though, is PR is very B2B.
When you're a PR person
and you're working with
a client, the Yankees,
you're trying to get them
press in the New York Times,
The New York Post, ESPN.
You're working directly with a human being
who's the gatekeeper to make a decision.
When you're doing social, you're dealing
with all the fans, and it's much more B2C.
So I don't have a problem if a PR person
or company is doing the social
for a company or individual,
I just want to make sure
they have a different gear
in their brand understanding,
brain, not brand, but that
was an interesting slip-up.
I just want to make
sure they have that gear
to know that they need
to be looking at this
as a B2C game, versus
the B2B game that is PR.
- [Voiceover] eastcountytoday says,
"Gary, love the iTunes touch.
When was the moment you knew you would be
okay when starting your company?"
- East County, right?
That's a little bone thugs reference to
episode, I can't remember.
East county, the moment I
knew that I was gonna make it
was the first day I walked
into my dad's liquor store.
And the reason I decided
to answer this question
and trying to find value
for everybody watching
other than me bragging about that I
had the bravado from day one was,
the notion of not even
worrying about that moment.
Meaning, one of the biggest
things that I'm trying to teach,
I'm turning a lot today.
One of the things I'm trying
to teach all my management
here at VaynerMedia, and all
my founders in my start-up
investments and my
co-founders in companies
that had meeting with my
co-founders at Resy last night,
the number one thing I
keep telling everybody
is to not worry about the
things that don't matter.
Worrying about or trying to figure out,
this is the moment when I made it,
is something that I think cripples people,
and I just don't even
think about those things.
I could answer this question two ways,
which are the two right
ways, which is one:
The moment I walked into my dad's store,
because I had that
confidence, or I could answer
the other way that's equally as true,
pulling on both sides
like a bridge, which is,
I haven't made it yet.
They both are right, and the
truth is, outside of this
question, I don't think about
it at all, ever, period.
And the reason I'm answering
the question is because
I'm trying to get as many
of you who are watching
the show right now to not
worry about those things.
Worry about executing,
worry about feeling good
about your life, don't
worry about making it.
Because making it is an outside force.
The inside force of you just doing it
is what you should be focused on.
- [Voiceover] Kyle asks,
"Gary, is there a way to
drive traffic to a website
when posting content directly to Facebook?"
- Kyle, yes.
(bell ringing)
As you can tell, that
Facebook post on my fan page
drove a crap load of traffic
to my Medium article,
which is content.
I answered this question
because I wanted to show you
raw details because I
think raw details is even
a deeper version of this
show, and I continue
to try to go deep within myself
to really drive you value,
especially because this is
only a 50 episode experiment.
Just kidding.
And so, the answer is absolutely.
Facebook is actually
probably one of the biggest
drivers of content
awareness outside of itself
to other destinations
in the world right now,
so the question is, how
do you do it organically,
how do you do it in a paid, targeted way?
What I just showed you was organic.
I have a pretty big foundation
of 150,000 fans on that page,
but there's people that I've
seen post content that have
800 fans, and enough people
shared it and enough people
liked it, enough people commented
it and shared it not only
within Facebook but outside
of it, that it created fire.
Facebook is content
awareness infrastructure
in a 2015 world.
So not only is there a way, I
think it's one of the singular
best ways, and so I would
highly recommend making
an investment in Facebook
fan pages, recognizing
the distribution
opportunities that it creates
for content you're putting
outside of its network.
- Hey Gary, I'm a realtor, and our team
puts out a lot of video.
(bell ringing)
- Ha, the ding.
- In Episode Eight you
said it was important
to put up daily content,
so my question to you is,
if you were a realtor, what kind
of daily video content would you produce?
- So that was a tremendous video.
Let's all at the VaynerNation
pay attention to multiple
things, including he was wearing
the R.O.I. of your mother
T-shirt, the fact that
he dinged the jab-jab-jab
in the background, a random man walked by
in the background, which is a reference
to some of the stuff
we've done on the show.
If you're listening on the
podcast, I highly recommend
you go to YouTube and watch this episode
just to watch this video,
'cause it was tremendous.
My answer is very simple.
If I was a realtor, the
thing that I would do more
than anything is actually review the area
around the places where I sell homes.
Let me explain.
If I'm selling homes in
Millburn, New Jersey,
I'm putting out a daily
piece of content reviewing
the school, then I'm interviewing
the individual teachers
if I can get access to
them, then I'm reviewing
every local business, the
Subway shop, the wine shop,
then I'm interviewing
literally people that have
lived in the neighborhood for 50 years.
I'm putting out content to
make you romantic around the
stories in the area, because
people pick them for utility.
What I mean by that is,
convenience of transportation,
how quickly from the
office, but they also pick
because of the school
systems, and there's a lot
of data out there on that, but how about
making it a little warmer and interviewing
Miss Robinson the third grade teacher,.
And then obviously kind of
the amenities around it,
the playground, the best stores.
I remember a realtor
telling me that people moved
to Short Hills because of Wine Library.
I thought that was cool.
It felt like such an anchor to that area.
And so what I would do is daily content
on the 20 mile radius or 10 mile radius
around the area where you sell the homes.
The stories that are tucked
away in the businesses
and the school system,
and the iconic neighbors
that have been around forever,
those stories are the narrative
that will create emotion
which will be on a tipping
point scale, on a 50/50,
may be the thing that tips
someone to buying your home.
- [Voiceover] Sean asks, "Gary,
most big successes have a huge
turning point where
things really take off.
What was that turning
point for Wine Library?"
- Sean, great question.
I guess there were some turning points
when the Wine Spectator ad that we ran,
the first New York Times full page ad,
the time I reset the score and took 50%
of the beer off the floor
and added more wine,
when I started WineLibrary.com,
the day I started the email service,
the day I jumped into Robert
Parker's forums in '97
and became part of the
internet community around wine,
the 2000 Bordeaux Vintage,
when we bought heavy,
when I first started
promoting wines nobody ever
heard of on email, Richard
Partridge Cabernet comes to mind,
when I hired Brandon.
As you can tell, there are
many moments that we made it,
but it was just trucking
along, building on top
of each other step by step.
My friends, if you listen to
two of my answers on this show,
you understand one very
interesting thing about me,
which is, I may have
the energy of the hare,
but I am the tortoise.
(bell ringing)
You know what I'm putting up there, right?
That beautiful thing you did, Zak.
Show Zak.
You did a very nice job on that one.
For everybody listening,
I'm pointing to the tortoise
and hare image I put out on Instagram.
Go check me out on Instagram/garyvee.
Anyway, when I made it,
the turning point moment,
everybody who's watching
and asking these questions
are looking for this
sign, like I saw the sign,
It's not that.
It's head down, you love
and believe in what you do,
and you just never think
about those moments,
you just keep trucking along.
It's lunch pail mentality, it's old school
Eastern European
put-in-the-work mentality.
I don't think about these things, guys.
The Fortune 40 Under
40 that just happened,
is that a turning point in my career?
Sure, some people now
think of me differently
'cause I'm in the context of
those people, but it's not.
It's just chug and chug and chug and chug
and chug and chug and chug and chug,
And so chug.
Thanks for watching the show.
You like that DRock?
(giggling off camera)
Don't edit that part, I
want your giggle in there.
Thanks for watching the show everybody.
Episode 36 in the bag.
Question of the day.
(sighs)
You know, to use this
whole theme of the show,
question of the day, very simply,
do you think you're a chugger,
or do you think that you
had a turning point moment,
and if it was, what was that?
And by the way, Episode 35, we dropped off
of the momentum of
Episode 34 on the banter.
I've told you about the banter.
I can't be in this
situation where I have to
yell at you about banter
and then it happens
and then you fall off your next episode.
I expected maybe 15
episodes, and I'd have to
talk about banter again,
but the community,
get in the comments. Get in the comments.
Thank you.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Oh crap, wait, subscribe!
I need subscriptions because I can't push
this many right hooks in
social, so subscribe!